well
good evening ladies and gentlemen our
question tonight is are we
alone in the universe
so welcome to this program the search
for life in the universe
of the 2010 world science festival
and tonight we're going to talk about
one of the most
exciting questions for humankind
a question of great interest to all of
us it has inspired
scientists philosophers even filmmakers
as we've just seen
what we do not yet know
is is life a one-off
chance a chance occurrence that only
occurred
on this planet planet earth or is it
as my rockefeller university colleague
christian de dub
thinks a cosmic imperative
that is the university the universe
is teeming with life we have just yet to
find it
this evening we will talk about how life
might have begun on this planet and how
we might find
extraterrestrial life in our solar
system
or even beyond our solar system
we will probably also ponder about how
the discovery of
et might change our view
of ourselves there are many ways to
tackle these problems
and tonight we are privileged to have an
impressive
array of panelists who are using
different strategies
in this search so i'm going to ask
my panelists to join me this evening
could you come on the stage please
so i'm first going to introduce our four
panelists
starting on the left jill tata
astronomer a founding staff member
of the seti institute who directs the
center
for seti research this year the
institute in case you don't know whose
acronym
stands for search for extraterrestrial
intelligence
is celebrating quite amazingly its 50th
year
of using telescopes to search for radio
signals
from the earth's galactic neighbors that
could indicate
beings elsewhere in the cosmos she's
also a member of the kepler space
telescope science working group so
that's jill tarta just
on her right michael russell geochemist
interested in how life on earth got
started
some four billion years ago
michael predicted the discovery of a
kind of
submarine hydrothermal vent later
discovered in the north atlantic
at the so-called lost city site
and argues that similar geological and
geochemical processes
occurring four billion years ago in the
earth's oceans
may have formed life's first organic
molecules
and metabolic pathways since 2006
michael has been working as a senior
research fellow
at nasa's jet propulsion laboratory
in pasadena welcome michael too
on his right dave charvino
astronomer he is a celestial detective
he hunts for earth-sized exoplanets
outside
our solar system that could harbor life
last year he used a group of small
ground-based telescopes
to locate a watery super earth just
40 light years away dave also uses
space-based telescopes to characterize
these
mysterious planets and is a member of
the science team using the kepler space
telescope
to search for exoplanets he is professor
of astronomy at harvard
and an astronomer at the harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics
welcome dave here too
and finally here on my left steve
squires
planetary scientist a veteran of special
of several
nasa planetary exploration missions best
known for his role as scientists
in charge of spirit and opportunity
those hardy little robots who have been
combing the surface of mars
as part of the rover mission um
steve's main research areas are the
history and distribution of water on
mars and the possible existence
of a liquid water ocean on europa
one of jupiter's moons here's the
goldwyn smith
professor of astronomy at conor canel
university could we welcome steve as
well
now ladies and gentlemen our program is
going to be really in two parts this
evening
in the first part i'm going to talk to
each panelist in turn
about the different ways they are using
to search for life
and also for the origins of life during
this part of the program
we are going to be really entertained
because they're going to share and i've
seen some of them already
some great images about the work that
they do and
that that's really very exciting we are
also
very privileged this evening because
we're going to hear some
completely uh new news released by nasa
only this afternoon about an exciting
discovery
um which has just been released from the
mars rover
spirit so we have to look forward to
that
now once we're all up to speed about
about what different approaches are
being used
we're then going to have a more general
group discussion between all of us
um all the panelists about the search
for life
in the universe so that's what we have
on offer for you and it's going to be a
great evening
you're going to have a good time just
believe me you're going to have a good
time
can i start with you steve now you've
been in charge of these two robots
wandering around mars for quite some
time now i mean um
they were originally only supposed to be
um for 90 days so what on earth have you
been doing for the last three or four
years
after those 90 days yeah but today is
actually day
2281 of our 90-day
mission so yeah they've uh you're not a
detailed person are you
yeah a little bit you have to be in this
job no they they're uh they're doing
real well both rovers are still up there
both are
still returning data and as you said uh
we actually had a paper published in
science today announcing uh
what i think is a pretty significant
discovery from from one of the rovers so
they're
they're still going well i think we've
got to know what is it what are they
well all right so we can go right to
that picture if you want um
there's a picture which i hope we can
put up in a few minutes here not that
but uh oh well what this is this is what
it looks like
okay so that's that spirit in the
foreground all tricked out ready to go
to mars i'm the good looking guy in the
white suit
why did you call it spirit uh the names
were actually picked as part of a nasa
outreach activity where children
suggested names
for the rovers and the name spirit and
opportunity were suggested
by an eight-year-old girl from arizona
named sophie collis who had been
born in russia and raised in an
orphanage and then came the united
states it's a very touching
story anyway so that spirit looking
really clean
doesn't look like that anymore
opportunity is against the far wall
there that picture was taken
uh at cape canaveral in florida about
seven years ago right before we launched
and the discovery what's it discovered
yeah okay what we have discovered
is uh in some outcrops of rock
that were explored four years ago by the
rover spirit
we have found carbonate rocks now
carbonates are particularly important on
mars for the following reason
carbonates are rocks that typically
precipitate from water
okay and water is an essential
ingredient we think
for life now we have found rocks that
have precipitated from water on mars
before we found
sulfates we found other things but these
are all rocks
that formed under very acid conditions
you know people have tried to describe
the results of our mission as water on
mars water on mars
until now it was mostly sulfuric acid on
mars
now there are organisms that can exist
in acid conditions but they're very
tough
very hardy very unusual the thing about
carbonates
is i mean carbonate rocks will dissolve
in acid okay
these point to conditions that were more
neutral more normal water more friendly
to life
so of all the discoveries that the
rovers have made over the six and a half
years that they've been on mars
i think this one points towards a more
life-friendly set of conditions than
anything else
that we've seen today do you have any
idea how old they are oh man i wish i
did
everybody always wants to know that
they're they're certainly very old
they date from i would say it has to be
say the first
billion or so years of martian history
so they're extremely ancient rocks
but the only way that you can really put
a date on rocks is by actually bringing
them back
and putting into putting them into a
laboratory and we don't have that
capability yet yeah there's the outcrop
it's called comanche this is a false
color image so it's not quite that blue
um but it's uh it's strange strange
stuff it's not like anything we've ever
seen before
and have you have found any other
evidence in the last six years
that would support the notion that there
was water on mars
yeah we found a lot a lot of evidence
for life we can flip through a few
pictures here and i can show you some of
them
uh really really nice evidence on a
number of forms
one of the most significant was found by
the spirit rover
when we were dragging the wheel of the
rover through some soil though
after about 800 days of driving around
this rover that was designed to
last for 90 days the right front wheel
seized up and so now when we drive
spirit we have to drive backwards and we
drag the wheel through the soil
but what we've discovered is that
there's a little silver lining to that
because what that wheel does is it digs
this marvelous hundreds of meters long
trench
through the martian soil is this an
example
yeah and one day the the soil
in the trench popped up as bright as
white snow we've never seen that before
so we whip out our spectrometers and we
take a measurement and turns out that
stuff is 91
pure silica sio2 now it's not quartz
it's not crystalline silica this is not
beach sand this is
essentially opal this is like the kind
of thing that you can form
in volcanic vents uh in hydrothermal
systems that sort of thing
so this points to an ancient
hydrothermal
the conditions that were more acid as
opposed to the conditions that
we see from the carbonates so that's why
the carbonate is saying that's why i
think
it's significant as it points towards
what would have been i think
more favorable conditions for life yet
what else do you hope you might find
if they keep going a few more
you know that's that's a hard question
to answer because
nothing that we've i mean i didn't
expect this
uh there was another thing that we found
in fact i think it's the next picture
that comes up here
there at the opportunity landing site we
landed and the first thing we see
sitting in the soil this is a picture
that was taken with our microscope it's
only three centimeters across
and the surface of mars that this place
is littered with an uncountable
number of little round things and
they're four five six millimeters in
diameter and they're everywhere
what we eventually realized was that
these are actually what geologists call
concretions
concretions form typically in
sedimentary rocks on earth that are
saturated with liquid water
there's some mineral in them that wants
to precipitate out
and it starts to do that and it
nucleates and starts to grow and adds
layer upon layer making a little hard
spherical nodule
it's kind of like the way an oyster
builds a pearl and they're just
bazillions of these things at this site
so what this is saying is that the
the water once soaked the ground here i
never
in a million years would have predicted
this so if you ask me what do i hope to
find
i don't know more cool stuff
well talking about cool places i guess
we could go further out into the solar
system yeah
yeah i think about europe actually when
we talk about just this thing real quick
before we go on oh yeah no sure i want
to hit on this because this is
this this gets to the possible future
of mars exploration a fascinating
discovery that has been made
just in the last oh five years or so is
that there's methane
in the atmosphere of mars now the thing
that's weird about that is that methane
is a molecule that will only last for a
very short time in the martian
atmosphere the martian atmosphere is
bombarded by ultraviolet radiation from
the sun
it's going to bust up those methane
molecules and they're going to last a
very short time so if you see it in the
atmosphere there has to be an active
source
on the surface somewhere so what
produces methane
cows produce methane it's probably not
cows
volcanoes can produce methane
microbes can produce methane
so what this is saying is that mars is
either a volcanically active world
or a biologically active world or both
we don't know
but we're hoping to send a spacecraft
orbit mars to look at the methane in
more detail figure out where the sources
are
and maybe understand better where it
comes from biology but no cows
probably no cows i would be surprised
because if there were cows we already
would have seen them for more so i feel
pretty good about that one
all right now the next thing you
mentioned was europa okay getting
further out in the solar system
you know if if i could figure out how to
do a mission to answer the questions on
this world
i wouldn't be screwing around with
rovers on mars to me this is the most
fascinating place in the solar system
besides earth
it's a moon of jupiter it has a crust of
ice
but there's strong evidence no smoking
gun yet but really powerful evidence
beneath that crust of ice lies an ocean
of liquid water
we can go to the next picture it
actually shows a close-up
of what the crust of europa looks like
and it looks just startlingly
like what you see when you look at sea
ice on the earth it's not hard to
believe
that there's water underneath that and
there's a lot of good evidence to to
suggest it as well the thing that's
interesting about that and we're going
to hear more about this
later there are places on the earth's
sea floor
where geothermal activity volcanic
activity from the earth's seafloor
provides energy that organisms can use
to drive their metabolisms and form the
base of this incredible local food chain
that you find at
deep sea hydrothermal vents uh on on on
earth
so it's entirely possible that if
there's an ocean of liquid water on
europa as we believe there is there
could be
life that derives its metabolic energy
from the internal geo
geophysical heat from inside of europa
so i think it's a fascinating place to
try to
to go and do a mission but you know i
know how to do mars rovers i don't know
how to do submarines on europa that's a
tough one
is it the geothermal activity that keeps
it liquid so far out yeah it is it is
essentially
what happens the the mechanism that
keeps europa partially molten
it's heating by tidal deformation what
happens is europa's in orbit around
jupiter
because it's so close to jupiter this
massive body it's distorted
it's not spherical it's got a big kind
of a big tidal bulge
but its orbit is not perfectly circular
it's elliptical and so sometimes
uh europe is a little closer to jupiter
sometimes a little further away
and as it's closer the tidal bulge is
bigger when it's further away it's
smaller and so it's getting flexed
back and forth and if you you can take
like a uh like a piece of
wire like a coat hanger wire or
something bend it back and forth real
fast and put your fingers on the bend
it'll feel hot
that's what's happening europa is
getting flexed back and forth and it
heats it
melts the interior provides potentially
a source of energy for life
so if president obama gave you an
infinite number of dollars
oh that would be nice how would you
design how what sort of probe would you
design for your rope
all right the way you would want to do
europa i'd want to do it in at least two
steps
the first thing you want to do is send
an orbiter with maybe a deep
sounding radar that can look through the
ice and find where the thin spots are
because it's probably not uniform okay
and if i got to get through that ice
it's kilometers thick i want to know
where the thinnest spots are
that's the first mission second mission
you go for it second mission you go to
the surface and then you would want to
have some kind of
probe that has a heat source probably
nuclear in its nose
that can melt its way down through what
might be kilometers of ice and then when
it gets to the bottom
and it's deploying a data cable behind
it
when it gets to the bottom part of it
swims away a free
swimming autonomous robotic vehicle that
can then
swim through europa's oceans transmit
data back and out
and back to earth it's a really hard
mission
it's a really hard music all right yeah
yeah you do that please
okay thank you steve we'll come back to
you a little later
dave dave charbonneau i remember only a
few years
oh is this it you want to do this
yeah this is how we landed on mars uh
you hit the top of the martian
atmosphere going about mach 27
27 times the speed of sound we throw out
a supersonic parachute at mach 2.
that hurts 18 g's when you put that out
we don't drift down lazily on a
parachute on mars the atmosphere is very
thin
we drop the heat shield we lower the
lander that's the lander there it's got
the rover all tucked up inside of it
we're still screaming down towards the
surface about 300 kilometers an hour
we inflate airbags i like the airbags
cut them free they drop to the surface
and we bounce
and we bounce
and we bounce and we do that for like 10
minutes and about a kilometer before
around
the airbags open up the lander and then
fold it up inside as the rover which now
has to kind of
unfold itself it has to do origami in
reverse
uh to turn itself into a rover i mean
watch what the wheels do here watch this
i mean i still get the ebg watching that
six and a half years later
um once it's all unfolded we take a
panorama we did this so upside down when
we drove off the lander
and then you go monster trucking down on
the martian surface
and off you go and six and a half years
later they're still going
good for it i think we should give it up
dave i i just remember it seemed only a
few years ago that um
one of the questions was could we ever
see
a a planet going around a star
now i think there's over 400 of them i
mean what's happened in the last 10 15
years
how have we discovered all those
exoplanets yeah it's been a um it's it's
um
really a remarkable time to be alive uh
if you're interested in planets orbiting
other stars and and that's the big news
you know it i think it's helpful to
pause for a moment and look back
through human history if you go back 500
years
and there's written records and there's
this thinking about if the points of
light in the night sky really were stars
maybe they would have planets
and if you go back even further to the
times of the greeks you can see this
yearning for coming into contact with
other worlds they didn't have
an understanding of where those worlds
would be but it's this very
human sentiment and we're all alive at
this magical moment
when uh we just happen to have the
technological ability
to actually find those planets orbiting
other stars and and it started in 1995
and it's been skyrocketing ever since
there's really
uh two there's two methods by which
astronomers have been able to find
planets in large numbers around other
stars and they're both a little subtle
we don't we don't go and take
photographs
unfortunately we're not going to be able
to send probes i wish we could
it's all through remote sensing one is
what we call the wobble method and my
guess is that this has been so
successful that many members of the
audience have already heard of the
wobble method
and and the idea there is you might
imagine that you know we probably in
school you were taught that planets just
orbit around stars like that but
actually the two do so
in a dance it's just that one of the
dance partners
is a thousand times heavier than the
other dance partner
but if you could only see that one
heavier dance partner which is the star
in this case
and you could look very carefully you
would see that the star is actually
going back and forth
coming towards you and away from you and
towards you and away from you
and you would know that there was
something in orbit around that star
and you'd be able to measure its mass
okay
and that's our first clue about how we'd
find planets orbiting other stars
and how would you measure them going
backwards and forwards i mean how do you
know that was happening
you would you would be able to measure
the change in the speed of the star
so if you look very careful at the light
of the star you would measure what we
call the doppler it's a dot
and it's the same effect you know if you
hear uh uh you know i've been in new
york city now for all the six hours
there's been a couple police sirens and
you know and it's coming just for two
just two
yes when it's coming towards you you
hear a higher pitch and when it's going
away here lower pitch
the exact same thing happens with light
which is another wave
and that's how we can find planets
orbiting other stars the other method
and the one that i think is more
promising when it comes to finding
earth-like planets
is what we call the transit method and
the transit method i think we've got a
nice
movie just to really illustrate the
transit method
the idea behind the transit method is
very simple is
you just want to measure the brightness
of a star very carefully
and then what you might observe is that
every time that a planet
passes in front of the star from our
point of view if you're lucky enough
that your line of sight goes through the
orbital plane of the planet
you'll see the star appear to get
fainter as shown here
and then when the planet finis finishes
transiting the disc of the star
the star will brighten up and you'll see
that happen again and again
and why that's so special is the depth
of that eclipse tells you the size of
the planet
so if you put them both together if
you've got the wobble which tells you
the mass
and the transit which tells you the size
then for the first time you can
calculate a density and that's your
first clue about
what that planet is made of does that
limit the
the size of a planet that you can detect
how small a planet compared with the
star it's going around do you think you
can detect yeah that's that's a great
question
if um uh if you were um you know hoping
to use a backyard telescope
uh to do this uh and you may not
anticipate this answer the answer is you
could do it
okay from the ground you could actually
measure the change in the brightness of
a star at the level about one percent
the star would get fainter by about one
percent
and actually if a jupiter-like planet
goes in front of a star the size of the
sun
it blocks one percent of the light and
actually most of the transiting plants
we know about have been found with small
ground-based telescopes that i can put
in my carry-on luggage some of the
smallest ones
it's really remarkable okay and so if
you're a backyard astronomer you could
actually do this if
the sky is cooperated here however if
you want to find planets that might have
life
then we're talking about small rocky
planets of course that's much more
difficult so for a star like the sun
a planet the size of the earth was a
hundred times fainter yet
so it only it only blocks one part and
ten thousand and
for that you have to go to space and and
so nasa has gone to space because that
that question is so exciting to us
and that's called the nasa kepler
mission and i think we have a i think we
have a
uh a movie showing the location of the
field of regard of the
of the nasa kepler mission what's good
to know is that actually
this field this group of stars is
observable to you
uh it's it's overhead you can see it
from new york city
uh during the summer months and it's uh
in the constellations of cygnus and lyra
near the bright star of vega which even
through local skies you could probably
see and so what kepler is going to do is
it's going to stare
at a hundred thousand stars and most of
them are going to be boring boring
boring but every
a small fraction will show these
periodic little eclipses and we'll say
oh
there's a planet and here's what we
think its size is based on how much
light is blocked
of course if you want to find planets
like the earth they only go around once
a year and so you have to be very
patient
kepler just launched last year but the
signal only happens once a year and so
you'd have to wait three or four years
to see enough of these signals to really
believe it
but this is happening now and so it
really could be and i'm a member of the
kepler team and
jill tardis member of the kepler team
kepler is performing
as designed and so if those plants are
out there
we we should be finding out about them
pretty soon how big tell us a bit about
kepler it's got a big mirror has it or
how does it work
yeah well kepler is basically a one
that the main mirror of kepler is about
one meter so it's about that big
and then on the front there's a big lens
so there's a big lens and a big mirror
and basically it
focuses the light from these hundred
thousand stars
onto uh basically the world's best
digital camera
okay and so we don't have an image of
the digital camera but it's the
the actual camera would be about this
big it's a truly remarkable engineering
feat
and then it's a very simple measurement
in principle which is that you're just
uh for every single one of those stars
every 30 minutes you're just measuring
the brightness
and measuring the brightness and looking
for that special moment when one star
100 000 gets a little bit fainter and
then it repeats and that only lasts
maybe 10 hours
and then nothing for another 12 months
and then it happens again so that's a
lot smaller than hubble for example
it's a smaller mirror than hubble yeah
the telescope can watch many more stars
simultaneously however you can really
only look at one at a time
and so if you're going to have an
earth-like planet that
presumably has to be quite some way away
from
the sun that it's circling from the from
the start so does that mean we really do
have to have a time scale of one two
three
years is that is that really what you've
got to aim at i i think it
is if you are obsessed you know we we
grew up
around a certain kind of star and if you
think that stars like the sun are the
best bets for finding planets like the
earth with life on them
then yeah there's no getting around the
fact that basically the temperatures of
the planets in the solar system
um if the planetary scientists will
excuse me are largely set by
the distance that they are from their
stars and and the time it takes for a
planet to go around star that's
determined by the distance so there's no
getting around
the fact that if you want habitable
planets around sunlight stars you just
have to look for these one-year orbits
however as it turns out most stars in
the galaxy are not like the sun
if if the sun is like a thousand watt
light bulb most stars in the galaxy are
one watt light bulbs they're christmas
tree lights
and so if they form planets just like
the sun then those plants are going to
be a lot easier to find but
but you have to look very very close and
so instead of going around once a year
they go around once a week
and what's so exciting is because the
star is small you don't need to go to
space you can actually do this from the
ground
and so that's actually what i've been
busy doing for the last few years is
is building a raise of telescopes from
the ground to look for these
earth-like planets orbiting very
different kinds of stars so could you
guesstimate for us i mean given
what you what's been seen already and
how many
stars um have shown evidence of planets
how many planets that might be suitable
for life are out there
oh
well you can say a lot if that's easy
yes i i think it's fair to say that
when we only knew about our own
planetary system we thought all the
other
stars uh in the galaxy would have
systems of planets just like our own
was that because we were good scientists
or good predictors
no we were myopic and we had grown up
under a certain set of conditions
and then for hundreds of years we'd
worked out theories to convince
ourselves that of course it had to be
the case
now predicting the architectures of
planets orbiting other stars is surely
an easier task than predicting whether
those planets
actually have life and we didn't get the
first part right
so what i'm saying is at this point we
have no ability to pontificate about
what fraction of stars
in the galaxy have planets like the
earth
that actually might be habitable have
liquid water but to give a number
there are something like 100 billion
stars in the galaxy so even if
the occurrence of life is very rare
there still could be many systems to
look at
and i just wanted to show this one movie
of our um of our mirth array
which actually shows a hunt for very
very nearby
um uh stars like i said you know these
low-mass stars what we call em dwarfs
they outnumber us ten to one you
probably were told in school that you
you grew up around an average star
that's totally false
uh our star is much much bigger and
brighter than most stars in the galaxy
but because those stars are small you
can see a small planet going in front of
them and so
this movie shows uh um a search that
we're conducting in arizona with
16 inch telescopes and if we find
planets orbiting those stars we actually
would be able to
uh to maybe even go further and ask
whether they actually are and have it is
so can you do even more than that can
you tell
something about what those planets are
like and whether they're likely
um to be suitable for life and have you
got ways of doing that
yeah i think i think that's really the
big question that we're looking forward
to right now
uh we're just at this magical moment
where for the first time because of
the kepler mission and because of this
project which we call
uh mirth uh because we're looking for
earth-like planets around endorphins and
we pronounce earth because it makes us
happy
because of because those projects uh
have just gone going we have the first
moment history we can actually find
planets but of course that doesn't tell
us whether there actually
is life on those planets just that
they're like the earth okay
and yeah i just want to jump in with one
thing about this habitable zone thing i
think the situation's even better than
the story that you're telling
because i mean the story that you're
telling is kind of a goldilocks thing
where
here it's too cold and here it's too
warm and here is just right
but one of the things we've learned from
studying our solar system is that i take
europa as an example
yeah i mean earth lies in the habitable
zone and europa
lies out of your notional habitable zone
and yet
the internal heat could actually produce
a fairly
habitable environment inside that so i
think the story is even better than the
one you're telling so there's more
yeah environment yeah the capital zone
is a lot bigger than
than the goldilocks story i think
there's more stuff yeah i think that's a
great point
so even in this restricted case we may
be underestimating
the environments around stars that
actually allow planets
and can we detect those i mean can we
are there indicators that you can find
from um earth right these are good
candidates yeah that's and that's what
really i think unites us as a panel is
the different approaches we bring to
to thinking about that particular
question so my answer
as an astronomer is that there are
inevitable
there were that life so dominated the
surface of the earth
that it completely changed the chemistry
of the atmosphere
and that's something we can study
remotely when you find a planet orbiting
other star astronomers have come up with
methods
to study the chemical content of the
atmosphere
okay and so it's that it's that
inadvertent
inevitable uh consequence of life on the
surface
reflected in the chemistry of the
atmosphere that we can study remotely
how can you
detect the chemistry of something so far
away how can you do that well
um what you do is you uh find a planet
that goes in front of a star
which of course is the whole design here
yep and so um
i think it's good to mention a bit of
history uh i'm showing here an
image of uh venus in front of the sun
and i don't know if anyone saw this this
happens very rarely
it it uh will happen in 2012 and then
not again for another 130 years but it
happened a few years ago that happened
i saw this from new york oh you did yeah
yeah um
and uh so 250 years ago a very observant
russian scientist by the name of
lomonosov
looked carefully and if we go to the
next image he looked carefully
when venus was just getting close to the
limb of the sun
and what fascinated him was that the
outer limb of venus was bright
and what he inferred is that venus like
the earth has an atmosphere
and you're seeing light refracted
through that atmosphere
and so he was the first person to infer
that planets other than the earth had
atmospheres and he was right it was a
remarkable inference
that's the exact same method we're
talking about when it comes to studying
the atmospheres
of planets orbiting other stars we wait
for them to go in front
and then we use the star like a
flashlight some of the light goes
through the outer parts of the
atmosphere
and imprinted on that that's the
fingerprint of the chemical content of
the atmosphere
and if we see things like molecular
oxygen
methane water and then we also know that
the temperature
and the composition are similar to the
earth then
that's the argument you build that may
be the best explanation is
that there's life and your instruments
have the sensitivity to see that light
years away i mean this is obviously
only tens of millions of um miles away
yeah no um the um uh the hubble space
telescope has
already detected the presence of water
and methane and atoms like sodium
and hydrogen in the atmospheres of
planets orbiting other stars that's done
that's old news but it's gas giants
those are big planets which are easier
targets
yeah to get down to these truly small
rocky planets
i think if we can find plants rubbing
small stars because the favorable
contrast ratio of having turned down the
brightness of the star
you can do it with the james webb space
telescope which i and i should mention
that a model of the james webb space
telescope is actually on display in
battery park and i think
there'll be even some stargazing there
saturday night so i think we could do it
with that instrument but then again
maybe those kinds of stars don't make
planets like the earth
and what's special about that space
telescope how does that it's
bigger just bigger it's more powerful
and it also works at infrared
wavelengths and and
so it looks at longer wavelengths of
light beyond the visible spectrum and
that's where these molecules are the
most
that really show particularly sensitive
to the um
chemical fingerprint of molecules and
it's those molecules that reveal life
okay i think to mike
um we've been talking about looking
for life um on other planets but um
we could get clues about how life um
first emerged on this planet because we
know it actually happened
um so how do you think how did life
begin
here on planet earth so this is my
favorite planet i have to say and uh
and and if
can we just have a slide please if it
was a water world
no the one before this this was a water
world so it's a very different planet
this is ours but it was
a third of the age of the universe ago
it's completely covered in water it was
an extremely rough place to be
many people might have heard of darwin's
warm little pond there is no place on
this planet for a
darwin's warm little pond it's uh it's
being impacted with meteorites
ultraviolet radiation
about 10 times as much as the today's
you can see that it's extremely stormy
there's
not a florida to stop the hurricanes you
have the roaring 40s so to speak going
all the way around the planet it's a
very violent
place there's nothing at the surface
that will help uh
to give us an understanding of life but
we the one
way we can think about this planet is
it's rather like an organism and i'm not
talking gaia here i'm i'm saying
what is it what does this kind of
organism do uh if we thought of it as an
organism we heard steve
talk about the generation of uh methane
on mars
and steve wasn't too sure understand
another nine of us are
what's the source of that method now it
could easily be inorganic it's likely to
be inorganic in other words
because there's carbon dioxide on mars
then
and as it interacts with the scent with
the surface of mars
then the carbon dioxide gets reduced to
methane
so but also methanogens uh
archaebacteria
actually produce methane as well so
hence the problem
but if we think of this planet rather
like a methanogen that it actually is
going to produce methane
why because it's surrounded by carbon
dioxide from our point of view this
planet is pretty oxidized it's got
carbon dioxide and water on the outside
it hasn't got any oxygen of course
because that's related to photosynthesis
but this planet so you can only get
oxygen from plants
yeah you can't get any oxygen
that's right yeah so this planet is
emitting
uh methane and what we would suggest is
that what life does
is to quicken those reactions so in
other words life has a job to do and
that's the way we should think about it
we shouldn't say what is life that is
definitely the wrong question
what we should say we should ask is what
does life do
so and if we ask that then of course
what it does
if you think about it it takes carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere
and reacted with hydrogen from water to
make a small but ever continuous number
of organic molecules
that's life's job if you like and that's
the way
i think we were talking about the way we
might be able to see it
now if we think about venus mars and the
uh and the earth
they have similar carbon dioxide or did
have similar carbon dioxide the
nitrogen ratios so in other words they
were all they were all possible
uh places for life to start of course
venus got too hot we can't tell whether
there was life there or not
uh mars seems to have been a likely
place we've had
life on at some time but of course
there's a detection limit problem about
whether we could find it on mars but
nevertheless
this is the kind of place that uh any
water world like this with a rocky
interior
we i would say would have life i just
one more thing about this and to say
why why can one be so confident about
this well we know that this was a very
hot planet i mean it's still pretty hot
in the interior
five to six thousand degrees centigrade
and how does it get rid of its heat it
gets rid of its heat by convection
convection in the core which gives us
the van allen belts and so on that
actually protects us from
cosmic radiation convection in the
mantle of the planet
convection in the crust giving us uh
hydrothermal systems and convection in
the atmosphere and so forth
now the paradox of convection is it
actually makes chemist
chemicals in into disequilibrium so you
get a chemical
potential generated because of
convection so convection satisfies the
thermal
potential and then along comes
convection near the surface
and we get this potential between
hydrogen from the planet
so this is emanating some hydrogen and
at high temperature it emanates carbon
dioxide
and what life does is it reacts the two
together to make either
to start with either methane or acetic
acid and my particular pitch for mars
would be to say
well maybe the best chance for looking
for life on mars is
of course to look for waste products and
that waste product might well be acetic
acid because
it methane is too ambiguous
so i think are you sort of arguing that
chemical potential
is is you've got to think about that in
terms of producing the energy for life
that
that it could utilize is that exactly a
cornerstone of the argument
exactly so in other words just like
lightning uh is
is related to the discharge of energy
and clouds and so forth and by the way
probably cosmic radiation is what helps
the lightning strike if we have the next
slide i can show you that
we would say that this is the kind of
system this is called lost city it's 600
meters deep
in the north atlantic and we would say
this is the best place for
life to have discharged its energy on
the early earth
because here this system generates
hydrogen
uh large quantities of hydrogen some
methane
as as these things keep doing we still
don't know
this real source of that methane because
of course the earth can produce methane
geochemically
and also a little bit of acetate uh from
acetogenic bacteria in this kind of
system so this
lost city system we would say is the
kind of uh reactor
the the natural chemical reactor in fact
my preferred word is
this kind of system which we predicted
on the basis of this hypothesis
is the kind of hatchery of life because
this is where
we have chemical disequilibrium we have
gradients
acting across we've got a thermal
gradient between the hot interior and
the cold outside
on the early earth just like we've been
hearing from steve about mars it was
probably an acidic ocean
so we've got protons uh trying to get
through the
outside of the margins of this inorganic
precipitate
and those the kind of systems that kind
of kick life into being we would say
life needs a bit of help carbon dioxide
and hydrogen don't like to
react what you probably know even
hydrogen and oxygen don't react unless
you strike the match
you could say that life is what strikes
the match between
carbon dioxide and hydrogen to make
organic molecules in water
so those and the two first effluents
would have been acetic acid or
vinegar uh by the so-called acetogenic
bacteria and the methanogens
making generating methane so what sort
of life could live in these well they
seem quite peculiar environments what
what could get on in that sort of
environment uh
well that's such a good question perhaps
the next slide for this one
now when this these are black smokers
and i think most of you
have seen black smoke one back please uh
most you've seen black smokers the
blacks
this is 400 degrees centigrade this
water it's hotter than anything in the
oven
of course so it would boil it would
destroy any organic
organic molecules but you can see that
life is pretty happy there's even a crab
living there in the kind of safety of
the cooler regions
this is pretty interesting though
because it brings metals into the ocean
and
on the early earth as on any sunny wet
rocky planet by the way
uh you would those metals would have
gone straight into the ocean those
metals are iron zinc
cobalt nickel we still buy those if we
need them from chemist shops
these are all important metals for the
way
life works there's a beautiful phrase by
david garner and he says
it's the inorganic elements that bring
organic chemistry to life
it's the inorganic elements that bring
organic chemistry to life and i would
say
right at the beginning when there were
no organic molecules on the planet
the first membranes the first
compartments were all inorganic probably
silica maybe some
uh iron carbonate and and some iron and
nickel sulfides
acting as catalysts to allow the
reaction and that came from here but
life didn't start there
and if we go to the next slide please uh
then here's the rainbow pool at
uh yellowstone and the tendency is to
say that these
cis these uh bacteria for example in
archaea there's about there's an
arc here that on the bottom left of that
diagram there
perhaps lives about 60 degrees
centigrade and archaea is a sort of
bacteria it's a kind of well
it's what's called a prokaryote the
three the three uh
dominions of life uh basically there's
the archaea and the bacteria which are
very similar to each other to look at
although very different when you look at
them carefully and there's us of course
which is actually probably uh symbiosis
endosymbiosis between the two the two
then came together to give
us but if i can get back to this the
assumption is that these
that anything that lives in that pool
isn't this extreme of fire because we
wouldn't want to live at 60 degrees
centigrade but actually
harv somebody called harvey in 1924
suggested that life might have started
in hydrothermal systems a wonderful
paper in science
because he said with so much iron and
sulfur there that life might have
started there
now there are extremophiles in this
picture and you can see this kind of
carrot
looking material and here's a carotenoid
and
it just is colored like carrot and what
it is
it's a kind of defensive molecule
against solar energy so actually i would
say
these sys these kind of reddish
molecules here these
reddish bacteria and neck slide please
and even things like
cyanobacteria and grass and trees
to me they are extremophiles and of
course we are extremely
extreme of fire but uh we tended to
think of a map from our point of view
that everything like us
is normal and everything out there is
extreme i would look at it the other way
around
michael this is my last question but
it's really difficult
really difficult even so archaea
they're very complicated how did that
come about
how could you get that complexity uh
so okay well the first thing is if we if
we take an analogy of a car
then we know we've got to have four
wheels and we've got to have a vehicle
and the first thing is we've got to have
an engine
eventually of course we can get
sophisticated and we can have a
regulator like a computer
but in the analogy the engine is the
metabolism
so first of all you had to have metal
you had to have a vehicle to us
that's a compartment uh and that a
vehicle
the the engine was driven by the fuel of
hydrogen and carbon dioxide and protons
so that gives us the engine and that
gives us reproduction because these
bubbling waters can give us bubble after
bubble after bubble of this material
and then of course along comes rna now
rna doesn't just come along you you
i mean for example all the kind of walks
of life we know that bureaucrats
couldn't have been there in the
hunter-gatherer society every everybody
had a job to do
in hunter-gatherer society and i would
say exactly the same
of life you can't have an rna come in
and dna is starting to bust around
metabolism
what actually happened was that co these
things like adenosine triphosphate
at atp you make your body weight every
day of atp
is one of an rna or a dna molecule if
you have that then in other words atp is
doing a job and what happened was
these coenzymes then eventually probably
could reproduce each other nadp
and thad and so forth and adp they could
probably reproduce each other and
eventually they strung themselves out
into making rna
and uh and i admit that that's a huge
jump
but the thing is if you think of it as a
chasm the geochemist runs this side of
the chasm
and the microbiologists evolutionists
are on the other side of the camp
they're not over there over there and we
are trying to kind of
make the links of course and uh i'm
fairly confident
okay thank you michael no jill
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
50 years
what is it you're looking for i mean
what is it that would be a signature
of extraterrestrial life well
50 years people keep asking uh you've
been looking for 50 years you haven't
found anything
right if we found something you'd all
know about
you need to think about that uh here's
the analogy
we've been using other people's
telescopes so we haven't been looking
very much at that 50 years and all of
the searching we've done today
is like taking a single glass of water
eight ounces out of the earth's oceans
and looking in that glass and saying are
there any fish there
are there any fish in the ocean well
there are no fish in my glass
so probably there are any fish in the
ocean
that's the kind of level of silliness
when you say that 50 years of searching
has any significance
so um what we're doing
is we're building a brand new telescope
right and i think we've got a
video of that um
right so we spent three years doing the
r
d to figure out how to do it we spent
two years actually building this in
northern california
today we have 42 of these antennas
working
as a telescope doing radio astronomy
and seti simultaneously 24
7 and this is the future that we see for
the hat creek valley in northern
california
where this array will grow from 42 to
350.
now to make that happen you just have to
add money
right we're we're ready so anybody who
brought their checkbook tonight i'd be
willing to uh
to entertain that and
inside these telescopes there's an
amazing amount of innovation
to be able to do things that we haven't
done before i think there's a still
that shows um what we call a feed
and you can basically think of this
funny buck rogers sort of death ray
uh as as being the aerial on your car
it captures the radio waves that are
focused by these
funny looking telescopes so the next
picture i mean perhaps
only a mother could love telescopes that
look like that but in fact
i do love them and they're doing a
fantastic job
and so you ask me what is it that we're
looking for well we're looking
for something that as far
as we know nature can't produce
so we've heard about
looking for signatures of habitable
worlds we've talked a little bit about
looking for
bio signatures on those worlds
what we're doing in seti both in the
radio here which is what i work on and
also in the optical part of the spectrum
we're looking for
techno signatures we're looking for
something that is
engineered so um
let's let's show the next slide this is
a radio
picture of the most distant
object that we've ever manufactured and
this is a signal
from that object it's the voyager 1
spacecraft
it's 106 times as far away
from us as the sun is
it's out at the edge of the solar system
it's about to go into the interstellar
medium
and i'm talking here so that you can
look at this diagram and
frequency is displayed horizontally and
time is displayed vertically
and um do you see it yet
how about there right and in fact
it's no problem at all for our
signal detection algorithms our
computers to find
these kinds of patterns we're looking
for things that show up
at a very small range of frequencies
nature produces signals that cover a lot
of the spectrum
so here in the radio we're looking for
frequency compression
in the optical when we look for signals
we look for time
compression we look for bright
flashes that last a billionth of a
second
or less that might be somebody's laser
that's being focused by a big telescope
and sent in our direction
or it might be some new astrophysics
that we don't know about yet
so these are the two ways we're looking
today
we think that makes sense we think
that's consistent with what we know
about the universe and the
electromagnetic spectrum
but we could be wrong we might be
looking for the wrong thing
um uh any technology out there
is going to be older than us or they're
undetectable
we've had technology for maybe a hundred
years
that could be appropriate to
interstellar communication
are galaxies 10 billion years old
so we don't know if there are any other
technologies out there
but we can be fairly confident in saying
that we are the youngest
any other technology that's there and
detectable
is going to be older so they might be
doing something
totally different they might be using
zeta rays
i don't know what a zeta ray is but i
wouldn't be surprised
if there's some physics yet to be
understood and some technologies yet to
be
discovered and invented and maybe zeta
rays is one of those things
so what do you do you do
what you can you use the tools that you
have at hand
i mean columbus didn't wait for a 747 to
get across the ocean
and so you just try and stick around
long enough to get smart enough
to invent these technologies and then
you start using those in the search
as well as the radio and the optical i
mean it may be that
some advanced technology has an
institute of ancient instruments
that they keep just for the purpose of
trying to attract
the attention of the emerging
civilizations such as we are
so that's what we're doing and the the
fun
thing dave talked about what a great
time to be alive
i got hooked on seti in the 70s when i
realized that
we as a species have been asking this
are we alone question for millennia
and what did we do we asked the priests
or the philosophers or whoever we
thought was
wise and we asked them what should we
believe
but actually in the middle of the 20th
century we got some new tools
radio telescopes and so i got hooked on
seti when i realized that i was in the
first generation
of people who could try and do an
experiment to answer this old question
rather than asking what should we
believe
tell me about how difficult is it to be
sure you're looking at something natural
or
unnatural that must be quite difficult
sometimes i guess
well if you looked at a star
or a galaxy or a molecular cloud with
this
type of instrument that that we've built
it would mostly look like all that snow
in the background there
we have built instruments what we call
matched filters
they're really really good at finding
this particular set of signals
that we've defined but as i've already
said
we may be looking for the wrong thing or
we may be using the right technology but
looking for the wrong kind of
signal and so
the the great thing is that not only do
we
have tools but they're getting better
every day this is all about computing we
can build
a giant radio telescope out of lots of
little pieces
and you can build an array of planet
hunting telescopes because we can
connect them with a lot of computing
and that computing is getting
exponentially better
so frank drake in 1960 did the first
radio search looking at two stars
with a spectrometer that had one channel
today i look at
multiple stars with spectrometers that
have hundreds of millions of channels
and in fact the tools i use today are
14 orders of magnitude 10 factors of 14
factors of 10
more comprehensive than what we started
with 50 years ago
and 50 years in the future unimaginable
it's all about speed we can do our job
better every day
it's really exciting so i wake up every
morning
and at 8 o'clock i get a report just
like
steve gets weather from mars i get a
report
of what happened in the last 24 hours on
our first
our four search programs does knowing
where there's exoplanets i mean
as we've heard from dave does that
change how you might look
where you might look for example that's
a that's a
question uh and it really is a question
so as davis already said
the planets that we found first were big
gas giants
and uh goodness they were in short
period orbits close to their star
not way out in the edge of the solar
system the way it
is in our case and we think that they
got close to their star
by migrating in during the formation
process
of the planetary system well if you've
got a big wonking giant
planet migrating in might not be so nice
for the terrestrials right it might take
everything into the sun with it
and so for a while it was a real
question do the exoplanet systems are
they the best place to look or the worst
place uh
now well paris are very
very fleet of foot and there are some
theoretical explanations that could tell
us that even if you have a
giant planet migrating in terrestrials
could still be there they could reform
after the giant went by or they could
actually survive
the migration that were stolen so
exoplanets are now back on our list
the little planets the m dwarfs that
dave is looking for
um for a long time we sent er no
uh this whole goldilocks story if you
have a small planet a small star
the planet has to be so close to the
star that
like the moon is with the earth it will
be
tidally locked keep the same face to the
m dwarf
all the time and that'll mean that
you'll boil off any atmosphere on the
front side and freeze it out on the back
side so
that's not going to be a great place to
live even though
they are the most plentiful stars well
again
i have to interject here the reason we
started looking at those
low-mass stars is because of a paper you
wrote i know
and it was entitled something like a
re-examination
of the you know habit habibility of
planets orbiting low-mass stars
we do we always reserve the right to get
smarter
and so we thought about it a number of
scientists thought about this
and gee if you see that atmosphere with
a bunch of greenhouse gases
and you can get wind circulating then
you don't have such
a dire situation and you also may not
have
a one-to-one rotation and revolution
lock it might be
um some sort of a two to three ratio or
something like that
so they're ways out of it again though
you know there are people who say well
em dwarfs
they're nice when they get older but the
first billion years
they're pretty violent and that um
radiation coming off of the star
may in fact take off the atmosphere from
the nearby planet
so there are questions but nevertheless
we're looking we're looking at stars
like the sun we're looking at
systems that we know to have planets and
we're looking at the m dwarfs because
those are our closest neighbors but
should we
do something like transmit in reply
okay um the fix the folks that i work
with the scientists that generally work
on seti projects
have said now let's if we detect a
signal we're going to tell the world
but we're not ourselves going to
transmit a response
until there's some sort of global
consensus about whether we should
because some people are in agreement
with stephen and think they're going to
come and trash the place
and then you know who should speak for
earth
what should we say um
those are very nice words global
consensus
you realize of course we've got no way
in heck that we know how to get that but
we try
and now maybe social the great thing
about the social networking technologies
is it may be exactly what we need to
hold a global conversation
on this question you know we don't have
to put people's butts on airplanes and
trying to bring them to a conference
center and
and most of the world's traditions and
cultures don't have the
the wherewithal and the finances to to
send people anyway
so maybe we can in fact have a global
conversation
about this question and i think we
should
as to whether or not their intentions
towards us
will be malevolent i'm
inclined to think if they've got the
technology to get here
they're a lot older than we are and they
can't have gotten old
without getting over the aggressions and
being able to control their population
and their behavior
something that we can't yet do good
thank you john thank you
so we now should move to our second part
a more general discussion about is there
life out there
so i mentioned in my introduction my
colleague christian dude he said
life is a cosmic imperative
is that the case or is it unlikely
which which side do you form we don't
know yet
we just don't know you're on both sides
we don't have i can't put myself on the
side we have
one example of life us
here we are we know that life can arise
but does it happen all the time when you
have
watery conditions does it happen some of
the time what do you really
need we simply don't know this is the
reason that that i'm pushing so hard to
try to understand whether or not there
was ever life on mars
whether or not there's life in a place
like europa because if you can
show that life arose
independently independently is key on
two different worlds in this solar
system then when you consider the
multitudes
of older of other solar systems that are
out there it takes no great leap of
imagination or faith or anything else to
believe that it could be
very commonplace when you say
independently that's key
yes because well what about colonization
from one to
well not just colonization you can
simply it's called panspermia the idea
that
life can be transported from one world
to another we have lots of rocks from
mars on earth
okay those were ejected from mars by
impacts that
threw rocks into space and they land on
on earth same thing has happened
impacts on earth rocks go to mars mars
and earth have been swapping rocks for
billions of years
and those rocks go back and forth with
typical transit times of
tens or hundreds of millions of years
but some of them take
seven months that's how long our
spacecraft took to get to mars and life
can survive in the vacuum of space that
long
so life from earth could have been
transported to mars
or life from mars could have been
transported to earth we could all be
marshals
so in making i'm going to come back to
the others but then making the decision
um whether the life is related you would
say if it was dna based
blah blah that would be evidence of that
it is
i i don't know i mean if it let's say
that life managed to get transported
from
earth to mars or mars to mars to earth
make up a number
three and a half billion years ago
divergent evolution they could have
gotten quite different from one another
in that period of time if they're
separated
that much so i don't know
carl's mickey i think anybody that would
tell you an answer to that question
would be over on that belief side and
that's the wrong
verb for science i disagree with that
i mean i'm not into belief i think that
uh the more the more we know the less we
have to believe
but the fact is one can look at life as
an entropy generator
we there's an equation called the the
rayleigh baynard equation
and you don't have to go to another
planet to know that there'll be
convection on a particular planet if you
know some
some of the conditions and like in the
same way if you know that there's going
to be a wet rocky planet with a carbon
dioxide atmosphere
then you have the next equation to tell
you that life will automatically onset
and it'll be pretty deterministic it'll
always do roughly the same kind of thing
it might not go as far as this but but i
would say the only real major difference
would be
chirality otherwise it's going to be
very similar because
you have a left-handed amino acid uh and
and uh right hand
left-handed amino acids and uh
right-handed that's the shape of the
that's the handedness of the molecules
and you've got to have that on this
planet
uh but i think that it's it's
conceivable that you would have
an alternative chirality and i
absolutely disagree with the idea of
panspermia because
we know in the lab how difficult it is
to culture organic molecules and if you
come to that
wet rocky planet that was our planet 4.4
billion years ago
it was it was a desert a water desert
it's very hard to get some to think of
something getting cultured there it's
the incumbents we know this from all
kinds of reasons
incumbents always win they hold they
hold the fort so
i think that uh it's it's a
deterministic aspect of the universe i
mean i wouldn't quite use the dude's
word but i'm sure he's right
go to a planet like this when they're
much rarer than we thought
that you'll certainly have life and uh
and after all you were getting excited
about europa
here here's what i worry about and i
worry about this in my business where we
look for life on mars and i'm sure
jill worries about it too the phrase
that i've heard to describe this problem
is
i wouldn't have seen it if i hadn't
believed it you don't want to fall into
that trap
you don't want to believe it to be true
and therefore see it in your day just
the protection of the next equation
i mean what's the problem we're taking
life too seriously life is an entity
generator we know it what it wants to do
it reduces
carbon dioxide with hydrogen that's what
if you think about it everything you eat
everything you see
has all had that effect it's just it's a
kind of
it's an it's quickened chemical
than i reactions i i i think it's it is
a very modern
point of view when i when i lecture a
big astronomy course i always ask my
students how many of you
think there's life elsewhere in the
universe and the overwhelming opinion
now
is that there is in part because there's
so many stars out there
and i just want to pause to say and i
understand what you're saying but i want
to pause to note that
basically that's a very contemporary
view that's a very modern view
it wasn't 60 uh you know if you go back
40 50 years ago everybody knew that or
that there were good reasons i think
there were there was life on mars
certainly a hundred years ago
that wasn't better informed necessarily
if we go back 100 or 200 years
there were reasons to think the earth
was really special and alone and they
were very deep-seated
beliefs and and so i i very much side
with jill that we have to measure and so
what astronomers can do
is we can go and find 10 or 20 planets
like the earth
that are indistinguishable in terms of
their their distance from their stars
their masses their bulk compositions and
if we interrogate each one in turn
and as far as we can tell they're the
same age as the earth they're made of
the same stuff
and yet there was no genesis it's a
barren rock and a barren rock and a
barren rock i'm truly open to that
possibility
and i think we would i think that would
have very deep implications well beyond
just science for how most of us view
ourselves in this universe or we could
find that every time the right chemistry
sort of comes together
you have life verging on the surface but
but the excitement is that we can go and
measure that
but i think that right now in the
scientific community both options are
firmly on the table
how would you stop it
how would you stop life emerging how
could you possibly stop it in this kind
of condition
how could you how could you stop
conviction if i hate to bring it up in
this audience but it's the
unknown unknowns okay but we
i it's the things i don't know about
that worry me okay
but we we need to have a model to know
what to look for
so what to look for i mean the old idea
is uh somehow or other
life is a reorganization of organic
molecules that reign in from space
now that is absolutely must be nonsense
so
it's much more likely that as i say it's
it's uh
if you have a co2 atmosphere and a rocky
planet then that's the likelihood of
getting
life because then it has a job to do an
energetic job today
so to me and then you can say right
that's a promising planet because it's
got it's got a co2 atmosphere i mean one
of
the things about europa is how much co2
is in
the ocean of europa now if there's
plenty that's fine but if there isn't to
me that would be
very significant to know how much co2 is
in the ocean
because if you don't have the co2
where's the carbon coming from well i'm
willing to buy the argument that
habitable environments are commonplace
throughout the universe i'm willing to
buy the argument that conditions
suitable for the origin of life are
commonplace throughout the universe
fine emergence of life but
i am because i don't understand
the process of the emergence of life i
am unwilling to
just believe on take it on faith that
life is going to emerge if the
conditions are right it's possibly true
i'd love it to be true i want to do an
experiment
one one last thing that i may say on
that and that is that
all of life sciences environmental
science and so forth
er oh it's all missing chapter one
because nobody's gonna hold
so so let's try and work out chapter one
so that's
the point and i mean i think that that's
it's maybe it's done
should we well actually i i'd like to
say that
it seems to me we've got three
astronomers here and someone who deals
with a much more deterministic system
than than we
tend to me a geologist all right um
but but i actually think what i'm seeing
and i thought this would be an oxymoron
that the astronomers are actually being
a bit humble
here um we've we've actually
yeah well we've actually had the
experience
of building new tools to look for
something
that we want to find out there and we
make the argument in our
our uh presentations and our
solicitations
that if we build something that can do
this better than we've done before and
do that better than we
then we're going to find this and
as astronomers we've had this fantastic
history
of building a new tool and finding
something that
nobody in the world had any idea
was out there and of course then we call
it
dark energy and dark matter and all that
stuff because we don't know
but we find new things we get surprised
and maybe that's why we're not so quite
so willing to say
oh sure yeah given these conditions same
thing's going to happen all the time
it's deterministic
it's inevitable you can't stop it what
about the numbers argument the fact that
there's
you know billions possibly out there and
there's so much time should we be
impressed by that
i i think that uh you know there's a
there's a fairly classic way to pick
apart that problem which is called the
drake equation
and uh basically what you do is you say
you know
something along the lines of what's the
number of the stars in the galaxy what's
the fraction that form planets what's
the fraction that foreign planets like
the earth what's the fraction of those
that go on to make life
and then because you parcel it up like
that
then you can say okay well we now have
answers
we know the number of stars in the
galaxy and i would to get to your point
about you know you believe that there
are going to be habitable
um habitable environments out there i
think that will be an answered question
largely because of the kepler mission
and the hard work of astronomers in
basically two or three years
okay that's a very exciting and that's a
big factor but there's that one factor
at the end which is
what fraction of planets make life let
alone intelligent life
okay and you don't know maybe it's one
in a universe
or maybe it's 50 percent okay
and and that's jeff and you and that's
chapter one and it's and it's and
they're just
i i have no idea which order of
magnitude it is
that that's really the key life makes
waste
and we can always predict what the waste
products are going to be
surely you should be into that we know
what to look for yeah let's go look
right but you need to know the waste
products
right you can't just say well it's
glycine out there in in the interstellar
space and maybe
life is being generated out there you
need to know that you're looking for
waste products so that
is one advance from this kind of point
of view
well we were talking about global
consensus a little while ago i don't
think we're going to get consensus over
this
particular issue with our four panelists
um
but just a brief diversion about history
of ideas because um
things have changed i think i've
remembered this correctly but three or
four hundred years ago when telescopes
were first turned to celestial objects
often it was suggested there were there
was life elsewhere sure
i mean that was initially then it went
down to there's no life anywhere and
then we had
canals on mars i guess 100 years ago
then down again and then up again
is there any sense i mean why is this
happening like this up and down any
thoughts on that well it's something
that we all want to believe right
i mean the canals on mars were evidence
of intelligent life the problem was just
that the life was at the wrong end of
the telescope
okay um and and and so we we want to
believe it
we want to believe it and it's it's very
important to scientists to not
let your interpretation of
the data be too colored by your desire
to find an attractive answer
okay another question are we being um
blinded by um our knowledge of what life
is like on this planet
i mean in other words are there other
types of life we could imagine that
perhaps we are not
haven't thought enough about how we
might detect them
and this of course begs the question
what life is which i know um
we rather glossed over oh yes
when i'm talking as an astronomer about
finding life
i think that the argument essentially
boils down to
that the chemical signatures that we see
in the atmosphere and the bulk
properties of the planet are
so like the earth and that the origin of
those molecules on the earth
is life that we just argue that the
simplest explanation is life
but but we would have no ability to
look at a planet that had substantially
different life and infer that it was
alive
so the only kind of life that i think in
the foreseeable future that we are going
to be sensitive to
in any in any meaningful way not i mean
you can make more general arguments
about chemical
physical liberty and all that and those
those we can debate but i would say the
only kind of life that we could truly
point to and make a good case for that
maybe you know someone who actually gets
to
dig in the dirt might believe and maybe
not even then
uh would be only life as we know it on
the earth so it's a very limited view
you know there's a there's a simple
practical element to this as well and
that is the things that we do
the telescopes like kepler the rovers
like spirit and opportunity
the the arrays that look for uh seti
signals
these things cost a lot of money our
rovers cost 800 million dollars and
that's a cheap mission
okay and so if you're gonna try
to design a mission design you know get
a government agency to trust you with
hundreds of millions of taxpayers of
dollars to build something and put it on
top of a rocket and send it into space
you better have a pretty good
explanation for what you're looking for
and i can't imagine trying to get
funding
to do a multi-hundred million or
multi-billion dollar space mission
to look for some kind of life different
from the life we know i wouldn't know
what to look for i wouldn't know how to
sell that mission i probably wouldn't
get it sold and i wouldn't get it
launched it might be the right one to
fly but i don't know what it is
but if you're going to try that
experiment you should at least first try
it on earth
yeah because there are environments that
where life as we know it apparently does
not com
is not it is not existing well
such as well i'm it's not clear
whether the atacama desert is a place
which
is so dry that there really is
no life or that well it's detectable
honestly
one of the paradoxes i have a colleague
who would argue with you but that's okay
you're you're here we'll take your work
so uh
the point i mean you're quite right
about what you're saying about the the
priciness of all this but if i were to
say from an origin of life perspective
uh the ratio about of of the money
that's spent on
astronomy and and cosmology and so forth
and the amount of money that's allowed
through funding of
origin of life i mean it's
extraordinarily low
people just don't want to fund or in
their life and yet
you need to understand that for what you
want to look for so
i would say it perhaps you know you
could speak up for this kind of research
some years back when i was just getting
working on the cassini mission to saturn
i went on a cruise on the atlantis 2
which is the vessel that supports of
course the alvin deep submersible
magnificent vestibule
vessel has done marvelous work at those
deep sea vents
that you mentioned and one night late on
ship some of my shipmates who were
people who studied these deep sea
hydrothermal events
asked me so how much does that saturn
bring mission thing you're working on
cost and i told them and i thought i was
gonna get thrown overboard right out
there in the pacific
three billion dollars so so michael
what what about this idea of a shadow
biosphere
what's your your take on this it's hard
enough to try and work out what's going
on
with i mean if you talk about a shadow
are you talking about different you talk
about paul davis's idea that maybe this
is just pulse but yeah
different metabolism is different it's
hard enough it's hard enough to work on
this one
but it looks as though that all the
metabolisms you look i mean there's two
beautiful papers in nature this last two
months by the folks group
uh showing that if you go back right
down the bottom of the evolution tree as
far as they can go
they couldn't find any enzymes that
broke down molecules
they were all anabolic they all made it
from the bottom up and if they look at
the
pathways they're all a simple the
simplest pathway is the one that makes
acetate it costs only one atp
it's extremely simple uh how could you
know if if you were going to design it
from scratch that's what you do and in
fact you can do most of that in the
laboratory
so i would say that it's actually
looking at us in the face a lot of this
and
uh because of a peculiar history of your
power and
uh the the idea of a kind of
i'm not talking politics i'm really
pointing out about philosophy and
ideology and method and how they seem to
to come together in the 20s 30s 40s and
eventually in 50s
to suggest that life somehow ever came
down organized itself
was coastervates on the surface of an
ocean and that ruled for about 80 years
i mean i think that that
you won't find one of those papers
quoted in the biological literature
because they said proudly
there is no evolutionary relationship
between prebiotic chemistry whatever
that is
and life whereas these kind of systems
that deal with inorganic
origins of life do have you can segue
one from the other i'm not saying it's
seamless but you can definitely see the
directions i mean you can see that the
minerals that
are precipitated these vents have
exactly the same structures
as some of the metal enzymes like
ferrodoxins and acetar quenzo mecin
phase
they're extraordinarily similar
everything was on a plate at a
hydrothermal vent
and it's doing and i just keep saying it
it's doing a job so
it makes sense just like convection
makes sense
you know conduction only can do it so
much and if you put a bigger thermal
gradient you automatically at the
onset of convection and you can predict
you can predict when it onsets and i
would say the same will be for
metabolism and we don't need to worry
about
more peculiar metabolisms because people
haven't studied
hard enough this one do you think it's
worth
exploring tens or even hundreds of
kilometers
under the surface of the earth for
non-dna based life
uh if you talk about the uh tom gall's
idea
yeah which he did change to quite a bit
no
i'd say life probably goes down to 15
kilometers it goes down to where
that would be an absolute maximum uh
four or five kilometers and more likely
but when life first started it probably
if you would
appreciate the hydrothermal vent idea it
probably then went into the deep
biosphere
it was too it was the ocean was a desert
actually even now there's not that much
not much going on in the wide ocean it's
only at the down draws and the updrafts
convection cells that really
uh and that's what the fishermen go for
of course so no i
that's the case i mean if you go to
other planets too places like mars
the best place to look for my life today
may well be fractures
deep down below the surface if that
methane in the atmosphere
is indicative of biological processes
it's probably biological processes at
some depth
so there's an interesting thing about
your discoveries
these are extraordinary discoveries of
carbonates so you've got a magnesium
carbonate and iron carbonate it's
fantastic and then
i haven't seen this baby yet just came
out today okay right so i'm behind the
times but
the uh could you think that you were
suggesting that
you probably had an acidic uh any kind
of water on the surface was probably
acidic
isn't it likely that you've got an
alkaline solution interacting with the
bat
the mafic rocks the basaltic rocks and
in fact what you're bringing
together is the you're neutralizing two
solutions and therefore precipitating
the carbonate right there it's gonna
it's gonna buffer the acidity the other
thing
is that there are indications that the
acidity on mars changed with time that
very early on the waters were more
neutral
and then as time progressed some of the
younger rocks is where you see the
sulfates the
the clear evidence of more acidic
conditions probably associated with
uh extensive volcanic activity that was
going on at that point
so my final question to the four of you
the more philosophical one
so let's say we get a signature of life
out there does would that change how you
would view your
self how we should view humanity are we
talking technology or ponsgum
i think we're talking how would you view
yourself if there was
an other life form out there well no but
i'm asking how complex is this other
life form can it talk to us or is it
just
well answer you can answer both okay if
it can talk to us yes if it can't talk
to us what would you answer
well i'll give you an answer from uh a
martian perspective because
that's going to be at best in the pond
scum variety
yeah um you know i i think what i think
what it comes down to
is could we find compelling evidence
that life
on mars arose independently on mars that
it wasn't somehow
transported from earth and i know you're
skeptical about the panspermia thing but
i i think you have to treat that
hypothesis seriously because the
implications
of life arising twice
on two separate worlds just in those
solar system
that's so profound so how it's that
question yeah because because
if i mean if it arose
twice or maybe multiple times in just
the solar system then this gentleman is
right
then he's right so the great test of
that but one would be very lucky and
that is if it had the opposite character
then sure and that would be one that
would be a great way to do it because
that would show
they were really two different
independent origins but if you can show
that it happened twice just in the solar
system then given the number of planets
that are being found out there
then then it's almost inconceivable to
me that the universe isn't just
teeming with life so to me just
one viable microbe from mars that didn't
somehow
originate on earth has just
profound implications yeah i
i i do think that you know why do we
have astronomy right well i think what
astronomers have done what we
contribute is to put the human
you know experience and pers in in in
perspective
and you know uh one thing astronomers
have have told us
is that the length of the human
experience the length of an individual
human lifetime or all of humanity
is a tiny tiny fraction of the of the
lifetime of the universe
that's something we didn't know you know
and and and and really makes us feel
quite small
i think the other thing astronomers have
contributed is putting in perspective
our physical signs
that we are on a nothing planet or being
a totally unremarkable star and that we
are physical beings are just
negligible in terms of the matter
content of the universe
i think the question of life would
actually be more important
than either of those if we found out
that life was an inevitable natural
consequence
and that we were but one of many islands
out there in the galaxy that we were
living in in a biological universe
that that had no trouble delivering life
and that we could someday even if not in
our lifetimes imagine coming into
contact with that not like not not
having a conversation but actually
reading it and studying it that would
that would
lead us to view ourselves very very
differently than if we found out that to
the best of our ability to build
telescopes and go out and measure
we were truly alone and that the earth
was it
so are you suggesting it's kind of
consolation that could be more life out
there or
more worrying or make us or our vanity
would
be displayed or what sorry i didn't
quite get your point
i think my point is that we would view
ourselves very differently if we knew
that our planet was the only
oh because you would well because you
would you would truly
think that you know biology on the earth
was
that there was something we didn't
understand that wasn't just chemistry
does it make us feel you know astronomy
is gradually moving us from the center
of the universe you know we're gradually
getting more and more insignificant
would it just make us even
less significant or even more
be more wonderful i mean things will get
more wonderful as we lose the mystery
things become more wonderful that's what
science does so
i would think yes it'd be more wonderful
and i fully expect
the second point you make but you think
it'll be more wonderful whichever
outcome
is true or you can't even know well i
can't even conceive there isn't life i
think we're taking life much too
seriously to think that we're the ones
you know of course it's like to me it's
inconceivable to you but to me they're
both on the table and i'm at uh
i'm torn apart
i'm with steve in awe of that pond scum
on mars
if that should turn out to be a second
genesis it's phenomenal
but i think that that seti this
question of are we alone being asked in
terms
of sentient beings somewhere else who
can
create technology or at least those are
the ones we might have a hope of
of discovering i think the search for
them
even if we don't find an answer
is incredibly important because i see it
as holding up a mirror
to the entire planet and when we talk to
people and we get them
thinking about the potential for
intelligent life elsewhere
what we see in that mirror is us
and we see that we are all the same
when compared to something that has an
independent
evolution somewhere else and so i think
it's
really important that's why i love to
tell this
story because i hope that it helps to
trivialize the differences
among humans that we find so difficult
to deal with today
so seeing ourselves as all the same
seeing ourselves as earthlings
first i think is an important message
i think this is the right place to
finish
i i want to thank you the audience for
coming i want to thank our great
panelists i think we've had a really
good discussion
so thank you jill thank you michael
thank you day thank you steve great
evening thank you
you